[Musique]
après avoir assuré pendant 17 ans
lacatus samedi soir madame mademoiselle
monsieur bonsoir laurent ruquier a
annoncé mettre fin à sa collaboration
avec léa salamé on peut vous dire que
vous avez marqué les samedis soirs des
français on n'est pas couché on est en
direct l'animateur a décidé de se
consacrer à d'autres projets j'ai
remercié tous nos téléspectateurs
d'avoir il l'amabilité de nous suivre si
certaines rumeurs laissaient déjà
sous-entendre que sa co animation avec
léa salamé l'avait poussé à partir
florence un artiste les as et une
journaliste à un moment ces deux
facettes travailler ça peut pas marcher
sa dernière éruption samedi soit défini
dans l'émotion moi en tout cas sûr on
n'est pas couché est sûre on est en
direct j'ai eu un vrai plaisir vous
allez me manquer merci d âme alors
laurent ruquier qui claque à
l'historique du samedi soir que s'est il
passé
alors c'est vrai que nous l'aurons a
quitté la case du samedi soir il va
comprimer les enfants de la télé
nombreux prime aussi sur france
télévision et j'ai vu delphine ernotte
certains patrons de penser les j'avais
discuté c'est un amour vraiment qu'est
ce que l'ado h l'ado est gentil
s'embrasser comme du groupe
les gens méritants tp dans toi on
s'embrasse et 1 bat delphine il adore
elle faire beau boulot à france
télévisions france télévisions ne s'est
jamais aussi bien portée faut pas
oublier qu'ils sont très très très très
proche de tf1 france 2 et france 3 avoir
chanté bien franchement non bravo à elle
est vraiment elle sait que je l'adoré
voilà donc à la rentrée dernière c'est
la chaîne qui a vraiment imposé léa
salamé laurent ruquier ne voulait pas du
tout d'elle la chaîne a dit on va mettre
les salles mais pour booster les
audiences donc truqué c'est quand même
un peu vexé et les oignons sont pas
flambé non plus donc il est très amer
pour ça quand elle est arrivée allait
révéler que son producteur producteurs
qui voulaient faire du c'est à vous les
obtenu une rallonge requis lui galéré
pour devenir une rallonge ils ont tenu
une petite rallonge c'était 145 1000
euros l'émission ils ont obtenu une
rallonge oncle et s'est dit si j'étais
tout seul on n'aurait pas augmenté et
pendant l'année ça a été très pénible
pour lui alors lui il prépare beaucoup
mais il se fie à un moment au plateau à
l'instinct et elle elle travaille à
l'oreillette elle écoute les consignes
de ne faire pas d'un pro il a été très
amer après chacun sait ce qu'elle veut
mais moi j'aime bien sûr mais je voulais
chacun des mois je suis je dis toujours
si vous le dire co animation c'est
impossible surtout ces colorants qu'à
l'habitude de l'année mais seuls elia
elle sait très bien animé sol donc c'est
vrai que deux franchement ça sert à rien
voilà on n'a pas besoin des deux pour
faire un numéro un voilà je le dis moi
je suis je ne pourrais pas faire une co
animation franchement voilà vous le
savez si ça peut quand même se dire ah
ils aimeraient bien du tout non mais pas
du temps mais benjamin et moi j'ai en
moi j'ai fait alors moi j'ai connu mais
une fois très bien il est super avec
avec eddy mais j'ai fait avec avec jean
pierre foucault c'était vraiment arrêt
vers saint amour après avec société un
code du monde eric dor c'était très
compliqué c'est vrai qu'il ya des morts
mais moi quand je dirais que jean pierre
jean pierre était numéro 1 voilà
les rôles soient très défini moi c'était
exigeant effet décolonisation complément
quasiment même c'est que ça de la
coanimation c'est avec l'animateur
extrêmement différents ça fonctionne
quand chacun sait qui il est et son rôle
doit passer par
ce qui était en liberté elle s'était qui
avait le clown et l'auguste faucheux
jean pierre foucault présentait vous
vous et faisait le clown c'est s étaient
complémentaires exactement d'acheter
numéro 2 c'est le numéro 2 c'est à ça
c'était champ mais ça c'était bien mais
là quand c'est tous les deux c'est moi
qui vais être meilleur que toi c'est
surtout que
j'ai trouvé c'est moi qui dis bonjour
bonjour il est 4ème bonjour 4 fort voire
arrêter les remet alors que je veux dire
laurent et je leur en ai dit je vous
jure il faut le dire aux téléspectateurs
mais moi on me dit ça moi mes souliers
mais laurent c'est la classe je suis
désolé mais alors je voulais à mes deux
mois on dit voilà tu es péri noyés en 24
la salle avec toi les mecs mais
technolia salam et on nous vous
n'oubliez pas sur un mais deux
franchement c'est il a la classe je suis
désolé c'était même pas ça selon moi
cette personne selon moi moi de son
émission qui commence à 23h30 et qui
finit à 3 heures du matin mais aussi un
moment je
reprenais message papal on n'est pas
couché non mais ça comme ça sans
décodeur 45 ruquier les deuxièmes
parties de soirée sur un sorin sur
france 2 n est ce pas à méditer aussi
suffit à 2 heures du matin
souvent les animateurs monte sur les
raisons de la fin de leur contrat là il
a l'honnêteté de dire la vérité ce père
qu'il ne voulait plus connus mation
france qui lui a dit c'est une co
animation ou rien du coup ce sera rien
l'émission sera présentée par léa salamé
ou quelqu'un d'autre ce sera pas en
étant direct avec un nouveau producteur
et ce sera pas en direct non plus parce
qu'elle ne veut pas faire de direct line
je sais que vous aimez beaucoup à la
patronne de france télévisions qui vous
dit je ne veux plus faire de co
animation sinon vous risquez de me
perdre ma part mais à un moment on ne
négociera en gagnant près la vérité il
ya des choix à faire mais vrai elle fait
ses choix ou peut ne pas être d'accord
avec ses choix en tout cas ce que j'aime
moi chez delphine ernotte c'est qu'elle
tranche voilà on aime on aimera ses
choix elle tranché moi j'aime bien ça
marche elle dit voilà après j'ai dit que
j'étais voilà quand elle a décidé de
mettre patrick sébastien
voilà dehors vous le savez que vous
savez comme je suis fan de patrick joret
pas fou rire la même nation mais en tout
cas qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
delphine ernotte elle tranche est pour
l'instant on va pas se raconter
d'histoires le march est là elle a pas
sauf la dictaure
le divertissement de marche pas de
l'encens fou vous avez la grille de
france 2 comme un allié solide
aujourd'hui voilà assez aujourd'hui la
grille de france 2 et bases solides et
plus solide que la grille de tf1 dont
clemex il ya quand même un problème
c'est vrai ce serait bien que le salut
qu'à la raison valeurs extrêmes avec le
service public se penche aussi sur le
divertissement il ya des français qui
veulent toujours c'est toujours
compliqué il divertissement social est
unique parce qu'ils savent pas trop
s'ils doivent aller sur des trucs très
divertissant passait très bien
répondu c'est très beau un peu au milieu
après voilà je pense qu'ils vont prendre
ed il faut qu'ils aient aussi des
animateurs pour voilà aujourd'hui ta
nagui qui excellent voilà on access et
puis après ça olivier michel drucker
mais c'est rick derrière c'est compliqué
les grandes valeurs
qui met un peu derrière cyril féraud qui
est top mais qu'elles seront trois
balles à la jeunesse même si vous dites
qu'il s'entendait pas ça se passait pas
bien moi à titre personnel comme
téléspectatrice j'ai fait deux fois
l'émission je crois que ça a marché très
très bien cette co animation bicéphale
moi je trouve que ça marche et voit ses
fans oui voilà mais après je trouve que
la manière dont laurent rey qui a
annoncé son départ c'est plein de
panache c'est super classe super élégant
franchement il est au dessus du lot et
ensuite continué après il va préparer
des prime bataille sur les prime pour
c'est que c'est eu des éléments de
langage c'est une réalité non c'est vrai
ce vote à quartz et vraiment je vous dis
c'est soit il dès lors de ses envies son
arrivée sur d'autres parient que moi
j'avais je leur ai proposé moi de faire
un pas vient ici et doré dr voilà un peu
en direct comme il a l'habitude de faire
voilà on est on est on reste en contact
et c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un voilà
que en tout cas je les aime bien parce
que i les fronts il est droit ne fait
pas de coups dans le dos laurent ruquier
il est toujours là c'est quelqu'un c'est
un des mecs les plus honnêtes ne la
télévision que les choses lui et tous
intègrent ça veut dire il dit un truc il
le fait il n'est pas voilà c'est pas un
mec qui est tordue qui fait des coups
tordus et c'est rare dans le milieu moi
je crois d'abord c'est une très mauvaise
idée d'avoir pris deux producteurs parce
que finalement ils sont retrouvés avec
deux producteurs et ils étaient addition
de vision différente d'aborder invités
il n'était pas d'accord non plus sur le
choix des invités alors imaginez bordel
ça joue lundi de source sûre donc ils
sont pas du tout entendu déjà ce niveau
là donc il a bien fait de marcher ans
que laurent je joignais rebouc mais elle
va faire sa deuxième partie on va voir
ce que ça donne mais voilà lui va faire
les enfants de la télé qui marche très
bien et il va faire d'autres prime voilà
il va proposer autre chose pire ils
errent tels tous les jours sa priorité
on devrait aujourd'hui certes elle c'est
le rêve de sa vie ça laurence a toujours
et le rêve de sa vie d'annie meert et
daniele grosse tête ce qui cartonne
c'est je suis ont parlé la dernière fois
avec le le très grand patron le grand
patron même du groupe ils me disent il y
en a qu il ya qu un seul qui peut faire
les grosses têtes aujourd'hui c'est
lorient qui n'a qu'un seul en france et
c'est vrai que là il est parti voilà mon
bord 25 ans de deux grosses têtes un
long correspond aussi à ce que voulait
faire delphine ernotte c'est à dire
féminisé définitivement france
télévisions pour l'instant seul
divertissement c'est compliqué voilà
c'est compliqué on le voit n'ya pas
d'ipod animatrice mm et elles ont
vraiment énormément de mal rousseau
laury thilleman pas mais voilà super
mais bon au 47 girish adore laury
thilleman
manque un peu de charisme comme il faut
des tauliers je suis désolé arrêter ça
j'adore loin mais pour l'instant il faut
que les taulières oui mais pas du tout
mais les journalistes l epa animatrice
au 6 ème
partie si
tu fais en direct site est relié situe
si tu fais pas en direct donc là y'a
plus de talk en direct la
sera le seul et qu'on dirait pas la sécu
et puis poté matin le plaisir c'est pas
le souhaitent aux camions on est ce
qu'ils ont
de tout de rien
c'est pour ça que je vous ai
qui change mais peut-être on n'a pas ses
mots c'est ce que tu crois qu'on a été
enregistré mais on vient des mamans les
pages - du tout au rien devrait-on
direct absolument rien ne connais rien
sur rien c'est ça la force de cette
équipe vraiment on ne doute pas voilà on
vous le dit on ne doute pas